- [Narrator] Big Ben
(energetic electronic music)
is tilting to the north
and keeps leaning about
a millimeter a year.
The 58 story Millennium Tower
in San Francisco has sunk
over a foot since it opened in
2009 according to a lawsuit.
And the former construction
manager for this 57 story,
77 million building in Manhattan
said it's leaning about three inches.
Its developer says it's
structurally stable.
Still, the building sits unfinished.
The Millennium Tower has
undergone a 100 million
construction project to
fix the unanticipated
movement according to its owner.
These issues all have one
main cause, the ground.
So to build taller
buildings on imperfect soil,
developers are using an old
technology for a new purpose.
It's called deep soil mixing.
- I think it has been a game changer,
completely game changer.
- [Narrator] But there are risks.
Here's how it works.
(energetic electronic music)
The incredible weight of skyscrapers
requires a strong foundation to stand on.
In Miami, Andres Baquerizo
is helping to build the city's
first super tall skyscraper,
the Waldorf Astoria Hotel
and Residences Miami on
ground that looks like this.
Layers of porous limestone and sand.
Not ideal for a 100 story tower.
So Baquerizo and the team are literally
changing the earth using deep soil mixing.
- At the end,
what you end up doing is
improving the capacity
of the soil to withstand better loads
and support buildings
or different conditions.
- [Narrator] To do this, workers bring
in a high torque or
really powerful drill rig.
This big blade carves
out wells in the ground
that can be up to 110 feet deep.
Here, they'll be around 40.
- [Andres] Imagine your kitchen
blender, but in this case,
it's a nine to 10 foot diameter blender.
This blender has some blades that
are going around the ground
and is shooting cement
through those blades.
- [Narrator] Then cement
mixes with the soil
to form a super strong
slurry called soilcrete,
giving the soil a higher load capacity.
- So what you end up taking
is a soil that would only have
a certain amount of capacity,
and you'll increase the
compression capacity,
the lateral capacity on it
and you're gonna make it really stiff,
making it stiff and almost impermeable.
- [Instructor] These wells are arranged
in an overlapping grid,
so that all of the soil is properly mixed.
- Every one of these cells, right?
That little circle there that seems little
is really between nine
to 10 foot diameter.
- [Narrator] It also makes the ground
almost impervious to water,
which at waterside properties
like the Waldorf Astoria,
means you don't have to fight the tide.
- Before, when you were
having the water being run,
it's a race against the water
to when you can do the work
if you're gonna have
a high tide, low tide.
- [Narrator] Deep soil mixing
can also help buildings
withstand natural disasters
like earthquakes and the hurricanes
seen in Miami when wind can cause problems
for super tall buildings.
- [Narrator] What happens
typically with winds
is that it will push the
building to try to tilt
and when it's tilting,
it's literally push the building sideways.
But more importantly, in the foundation,
if you realize if it's going this way,
one side is pushing and
the other one is lifting.
So now you have a tension condition
and a compression condition.
If you increase the capacity
of the piles to not be bent laterally
and increase the compression capacity,
and a little bit of the tension,
it's gonna end up helping the
building to be more stable.
- [Narrator] Deep soil mixing's
ground-hardening abilities
not only make a building
like this possible, they
make it more profitable.
For example, developers have been able
to add more high floor condos
than they would have if
the building was shorter.
They'll start at $10 million each
and will look like these renderings.
- More people are willing
to say, you know what?
It's interesting, let's go for it.
So you're beginning to see this increase
of the size of the city
and the height of the buildings.
- [Narrator] The
construction company building
the Waldorf Astoria Tower is
now using deep soil mixing
for shorter residential projects
across the country and around the world.
They've used it here, here,
and here to prevent soil
shifting under skyscrapers,
and that's just one company's projects.
Other companies also
have projects underway
across the globe,
but the method comes with some risks.
- So if a building was
demolished to be able
to put a new building and they
left anything made by man,
the big blender is coming into the ground
and shooting cement will
hit this obstruction
and may shift out of
location or damage the tool.
If you get shift out of location
and you don't realize that it happened,
then during the excavation process,
you wind up getting some water intrusion.
- [Narrator] That's when water
flows into the excavation.
A small amount is normal,
but any flow larger
than a garden hose can be hard to fix.
Take a nearby Miami
project, UNA Residences,
as an example.
In March, 2022, water entered
the unfinished foundation
during deep soil mixing,
creating what looked like a lagoon
and concerning residents.
The developers said that
construction is back underway
and some land like beach
sand is just too soft
for deep soil mixing.
If the technique is used on soil
that's not quite right,
the layer of soilcrete can crack.
- When it begins to break,
the difficult thing is, in most cases,
you almost have to start from scratch,
because if you already
found you have a weakness,
it's not something you can reinforce
as the water will always want to come in.
- [Narrator] Previously, deep
soil mixing was mainly used
for industrial sites like oil refineries
where the land needed
to hold heavy equipment.
- Miami was the first
city, where at some point,
the industry realized that this condition
could help us improve the
capacity of onsite soils.
And from Miami, there has been developing
is now beginning to go into
other places of the world.
- [Narrator] But due to the
unique engineering challenges
that Miami's sandy soil presents,
Andres's team of engineers
are paying close attention
to the construction.
The progress the team makes here will help
inform the company's
engineers around the globe
on how to make more stable
ground for their buildings.
- As we use it more,
we have been able to
understand better the system
to keep using their benefits
into the benefit of the buildings.
So for me, has been a game changer.